how to manage your Halloween candy from
your nobs register dietitian I really do
see Halloween as a great opportunity to
help neutralize the Laura sweets as
forbidden Foods worthy of overeating so
this is our Halloween candy protocol
101 step one allow yourself or your kids
unlimited access to their Halloween
candy on Halloween night if you or your
kids are typically restricting sugar
they probably will overeat and that is
totally fine that's a teachable moment
for them to feel that sensation in their
body two allow another few days of
unlimited candy post Halloween night one
is an experiment but we really need to
follow through with some consistency for
our kiddos to really be able to trust
that the goodies are not gone forever
and their body signals can be trusted
and then finally step three Implement a
sweet Protocol no different than the
rest of the year in my family this means
my kids get to choose a piece for their
lunch and or dinner so it's not like
poof there's no candy ever ever again
happy trick- or-
treating oh good